two what is up people of the world we
are back live people said it couldn't be
done I was suspended for a week I'm
aware yeah I saw people were saying that
they're never going live again yeah
because Ethan can't handle his [ __ ] like
an alcoholic who always blacks out and
pukes right but that's not me no never
Life is In My Blood
and I will go live until the day we are
permanently suspended
all right
which is not gonna happen by the way
it's not gonna happen no never uh
today's podcast is sponsored by the
ordinary
uh thank you so much and by Ela Klein of
course but I'll talk about that in a sec
we are joined here
by the very funny the very handsome
according to Hassan [ __ ] right yeah
that's that's like the biggest W ever I
think right Curtis Connor
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
thank you how are you thank you for
being here so nice to meet you yeah nice
to meet you too man thanks for having me
on this is uh this is crazy it's awesome
it is it's crazy it is crazy I have been
watching your videos for like a super
long time so it's uh thanks it's [ __ ]
crazy man I would I would always uh
watch the one video you did about the
that dude who like pretended to be on
Ellen oh yeah that was so crazy yeah
sometimes like
that was like the blessing and the
problem with my content is that it was
so dependent on
something like that right into my life
and that was one of the best things that
ever rolled into my life yeah I blew my
mind it's so to this day I think about
it all the time I'm [ __ ] crazy that
guy I wonder what he's up to can we get
a can we get a a life update on him yeah
that'd be great yeah I'll look into it
he's up to something he's got it yeah
yeah so
um a year on tour currently I just want
to uh you're on tour by the way if you
guys want to watch Curtis on tour or
join uh the show yeah we're going to
shop.curtisconnor.com
right that's correct awesome let's go
and you can get tour tickets there you
can also watch them on YouTube just type
his name Curtis Connor I mean it's not
that complicated you guys can figure it
out yeah it's pretty simple but it looks
like you're been pretty busy huh yeah
yeah super busy tour's been uh crazy I
also just got
married yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the
other thing uh your wife Jen is here
with you and uh congratulations to you
both thank you did you guys elope I
guess yeah I guess that's what you would
call it yeah we uh well that's what we
were saying it was we got I think Jenna
got one comment if someone was like this
doesn't count as a loping which I don't
know what it really I guess the loping
is like when you don't tell anybody and
you just do it yeah I guess since we had
some friends there I guess
yeah yeah sort of did your family know
yeah they knew that we were going to do
that
um but yeah
it's an elope yeah thank you yeah yeah
it was an allotment it was beautiful uh
we went to Italy and it was uh it was
the best we had a bunch of [ __ ]
awesome uh pasta and oh really drink
pasta
Pasta Pasta paste whatever you people
know what you mean the [ __ ] you know
the dough in the water the donut water
yeah and then Tomatoes
um yeah it was great I've never been
there but me and Eli we were talking
before the show I wish I could go there
but we have two young boys yeah and that
my life is over in the best way possible
right yeah well they'd like it too Ela
is five and actually she's 15 Italian
Dan
actually I don't know if you know this
but my sons are seven and a half percent
Italian
[Music]
you gotta bring him back to their
Homeland it is
pretty Epic
Italian moment for sure yeah what would
you think about the is the posture there
really that better like just be totally
[ __ ] honest it is I'll go on record
it is a lot better I don't know what
they do or like something is different
than like the water or like the grains
or whatever that they use but like
because here like I was just saying this
morning to Jenna like I feel like like
[ __ ] like big here like I'm just
feeling like bigger when you eat pasta
or just or just anything in general like
food in America like in North America
after being in Italy it's like the food
is I don't know I could literally eat
like a million pounds of whatever and
then just like walk around and be and
feel so skinny why is that I don't know
I honestly don't know it's kind of
[ __ ] up actually scary yeah putting on
our food corn syrup yeah it's got to be
the corn syrup it's got to be dead I
don't know there's really nothing more
American than corn syrup when you get
down to it at this point yeah we just
grind that corn up boy and foot and
everything looks cool cornball
the olive I mean corn syrup is [ __ ]
really good so I mean I get it yeah
forget about it I love corn syrup uh
sometimes I just drink it in the morning
start my day right just straight syrup
but yeah that's crazy yeah so how many
how many people are in your guys's
wedding I think
eight of us oh just eight yeah
six guests you only have six guests and
you don't know the number yeah I mean
even that was way too much man and was
it just friends yeah it was friends it
was our like my one friend uh Jacob
who's on tour with me he like officiated
it which was nice
um and our other friend Dean he was like
the ring bearer which was him just
giving just giving us the Rings um
um just handing it to you don't have to
walk at all he bared it yeah like Sam
from Lord of the Rings yeah I made him
dress up like Sam
yeah he's only had allowed the Lambda
spread or whatever it's called Uh he had
a bad time saltine crackers yeah yeah I
dressed up a Smeagol
um he uh and then we had uh our friends
Danny Danny Gonzalez you know you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah and been on the show
yeah Danny and uh Greg yeah and his wife
Laura uh also Jacob's partner eilish and
obviously me and Jenna and our other
friend Hannah and also our friend Lizzy
was the photographer and it was [ __ ]
awesome
um that sounds awesome that sounds like
a perfect wedding you know it's kind of
nice to do that with the people that you
really want were your parents invited
uh well no well okay well I'm not
curious on the logistics yeah we're
gonna do like a family one next year for
okay so Jen is saying they're gonna do a
family yeah episode next year right an
episode yeah a family episode yeah yeah
I got my yeah you're a podcast mode yeah
yeah we started this marriage episode in
Italy
um so just the Friends yeah it was nice
that's awesome you know and it's like it
was small enough for like you know
people uh you didn't have to worry
because I feel like you hear about
weddings of like 200 like 300 people and
it's like I don't
and even like even our wedding was six
people it was like so it was so much
[ __ ] work just like playing
everything for six people so I can't
even imagine like 100 people I probably
would have that was my experience
because I me and my wife we got married
in Israel I don't have any family there
so our wedding party was like 200 people
on her side which apparently was light
is light for Israel that's crazy and
then five people from my side I didn't
know 95 other percent of the people
there was right though yeah I mean it's
a different beat there exactly yeah I
mean but yeah it was great and it's uh
and it was it was gnarly going from
there to all the way just right back to
like
tour mode immediately it's been it's
been a lot but there's only four shows
left to the tour oh we're [ __ ] done
so there it is yeah
thank you thanks for that yeah
um since June
it's been a long time it's been a lot
how many seats are you doing on these uh
I think like the average event like
theater size is like
like between like 12 and 14. damn let's
[ __ ] go right now
thank you thank you yeah pretty crazy
the biggest one we did was the Chicago
Theater which was like 3 500. uh that
was gnarly it wasn't like 100 yeah sure
let's go
and are you doing like stand-up material
what's the show like yeah it's all stand
up uh because I I actually started I did
stand up before I did like any sort of
like online content
um that's how I like started I guess
like getting into comedy
uh so obviously this is like this has
been the goal for like the whole thing
obviously you know
um but uh yeah it's all stand up I got
my two like best friends who I like like
I've known for like 10 years now uh they
open the show for me they both do like
15 minutes and then I do like an hour
and an hour of material yeah yeah it's
surprisingly I mean I've been doing it
for a while but it definitely it goes by
really quick like I feel like when I'm
done I'm like I'm like sad because I'm
like I just I want to keep going but you
know that's just that's just that's not
easy to put on an hour of material you
know what I mean yeah oh by the way we
had a comment from a member Goose says I
saw Curtis on tour in Buffalo this year
and it was such a fun show get those
tickets people let's fire it is
yeah that's huge yeah nice ladies and
gentlemen yeah ghosts
hey can you hit us with uh we are all
domestic terrorists Act
it's just because yeah and then we are
all domestic terrorists
we always pop after that that was
actually from the uh
OPEC dance uh CPAC yes I don't know what
that what to see it's though it's like
the annual Republican uh oh convention
and they straight up opened it with that
swear to [ __ ] God damn hit me with it
again gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists
yeah
pretty incredible stuff there it is yeah
I mean they always say end with your you
know you start strong and then you
finish strong right like your best
material and then your worst stuff and
that's powerful that's hard to talk that
I'm gonna start saying that in my shows
you know that's that's not a bad idea a
good win the crowd over with that yeah
for sure
um
so basically what's your schedule like
let's say you're gonna finish touring in
June or then you're gonna kind of take a
little break go back to making YouTube
videos yeah I finished tour in Vancouver
on Sunday I think and then we're heading
back to pick up our dog which I'm very
excited for uh and then yeah just pretty
much stay at home make videos you know
it's been like it's been like a crazy
amount of anxiety like being on tour and
not being able to make as many videos as
I want to make
um because you know
when you're not doing that for a while
it's like well everyone's just gonna
[ __ ] up they're gonna remember me yeah
but they're buying your ticket so I
think I remember you that's true yeah
yeah that's comforting to know that is
like the one thing it's like if I was
doing if I had to not do YouTube and
then do shows and then like no one was
buying tickets
that'd be [ __ ] gnarly yeah but
getting people getting people to
actually converting people to buying
tickets and going somewhere it's
probably one of the hardest things you
can do it is difficult yeah it is it is
pretty tricky you know conversion rates
and all that you know crunchy numbers
yeah crunching numbers yeah a lot of
number crunching but yeah I mean it's
I'm yeah I'm definitely very lucky that
people are actually showing up and the
crowds we've been getting been [ __ ]
incredible that's awesome man so yeah
thank you thanks
um what's your best joke no I'm just
kidding
we are all domestic
oh I forgot to say I just there's a
couple of things at the top of the show
I wanted to say on Friday we have this
is a guest I've been trying to get
forever
astrophysicist Avi Loeb is flying in to
answer all of our questions about space
wow a bit of a downgrade for me but yeah
well well what is dark matter can you
tell me all right
well it's the stuff in between stuff
right
[Applause]
oh well oh do you actually want you I
actually think you're correct with that
well I think I'm paraphrasing but isn't
it like dark dark it makes up most of
like the universe that's true that's
true that's mixed up that's true the
majority of mass right in the universe
yeah it doesn't interacts with visible
light so we don't know where it is what
it looks like we can't find it but we
know it's there right
and that
is dark matter thank you ladies and
gentlemen our Dark Energy maybe right
yeah yeah that's cooler it's not like
video game and stuff I told me so
hopefully he knows though oh we had got
an official a dark matter is a
hypothetical form of matter thought to
account for approximately 85 of the
matter in the universe damn it's called
Dark because it does not appear to
interact with the electromagnetic field
which means it does not absorb reflect
or emit electromagnetic radiation is
therefore difficult to detect
[Applause]
we wouldn't be here without it probably
who knows hypothetically I mean we I
mean we'll probably you'll probably know
more on Friday yeah Friday yeah I got a
lot of questions yeah can you let me
know what he says about my definition
okay someone write that down you said
it's the stuff in between stuff yeah
okay we'll have him rate that we'll have
him write that and I'll let you know
yeah that's a good idea and do you have
any other questions for him
uh
so he's like he's an astrophysicist yeah
yeah
um
I mean like you could ask him about like
Astro World or something AstroWorld yeah
what's his thoughts on the Stampede if
he had anything to do with that okay
that's a good one maybe you got that
that'd be actually a really fun way to
open yeah so tell me why didn't you do
more
disasters
I feel like there's more you've been you
could have been you know been doing to
prevent that it's like an allig question
yeah yeah so funny so you were at
AstroWorld right
[Laughter]
oh one other thing the members uh only
podcast is up I talk about my suspension
there because nobody wants to hear me
talk about that dumb [ __ ] so if you want
to hear me talk about it it's up for
members thank you God bless so thank you
thank you peace and love peace and love
peace oh also one other thing sorry
there's a [ __ ] YouTube changed this
[ __ ] and God damn them we're getting
like a million posts on our subreddit
here's us let's go uh we're getting a
mailing post on the starboard because
when you go to video
it no longer shows lives and everyone's
like yo why don't you delete all their
videos you have to click live which is
dumb as hell
thank you thank you thank you
yeah
so there it is uh
excellent
good good
what's going on with you and hassano why
are you guys like you know we have a
podcast together so
yeah you do this that's pretty cool man
uh yeah I mean
a lot I don't know a lot I was supposed
to go on a stream yesterday but I didn't
have time and I feel bad while you stood
him up after all the nice things he said
I didn't stand okay
let the record show okay I
invited Hassan to my show in La okay oh
that's a big one and I put him on the
list and everything that's huge
and uh
he ghosted you he didn't show up he left
the tickets at Will Call yeah I guess so
oh yes hold on yeah fix my [ __ ] yeah
it gets pretty good go ahead I'm not
sorry I didn't mean to distract no it is
it's not distracting at all
yeah
uh so yeah I mean I I get it you know
he's busy you know I get it not that
busy bro he just sits in his room all
day right I mean at the end of the day
that's all he [ __ ] does that's true
and it was out it was like a later show
it was like after the stream with his
stream would have been done did he give
you any excuse any reason
no I mean maybe it was a
miscommunication you know maybe he just
didn't you know maybe he didn't know
that if you pull up the text can you see
I want to gauge the communication uh
yeah efficiency because I can call him
we can get him on the phone and see yeah
let's see we'll squash the beef right
now that is clearly so in a way you
blowing him off was Retaliator
yeah maybe subconsciously yeah it was my
yeah because I mean it it the other
thing it was like I
maybe I should have been more clear
about like what my plans were yesterday
for his stream you know because I was
like because I had to I did I did this
like q a thing at Twitter in the morning
I was like if I have time
I'll go to your stream after you know
we'll hang out maybe like an hour or
something and then I'll I'll go meet
everyone else that I was gonna hang out
with and then uh
and then after that he like tweets and
is like Curtis is coming on the stream
today and I was like bruh I don't know
if that's gonna happen yet so it was
like it was a whole thing yeah let's
figure out what's going on here this is
this is why we're here you know I'm a
mediator of sorts yeah that means a lot
yeah okay so I said yo big dog you're on
the list for my Late Show in La this
Friday if you want to pull up that was
at
um 3 45 in the morning that's a late
text wait I think we might have been an
outlet or in Italy I think we were in
Italy so we were like or Canada we were
in like different times and like he got
it at 3 40 AM
I guess so yeah yeah yes okay yeah and
then he said uh or in response to this
and no mention of the show at all he
says when are you in L.A
and then and then I say I get there
Friday
afternoon for my show
and then I'm back from the 31st to the
second which is today right now right
now recording H3 on the second in the
afternoon
and then on and then no response and
then on uh Monday
I think the day of my show I think
I don't know whenever Monday was you
know what okay I don't know he says
okay that was sorry that was a day that
I got back from San Francisco after my
show got it you're here today pull up
and then I said I get there at noon I
gotta go I gotta go do my stuff I got a
Halloween costume shopping we're in a
Harry Style show tonight so you got a
lot of stuff I got a busy day you know
very clear about him with that and then
it was like
yeah and then he said come over today
and then I said same here and then we
then went over through text and that was
pretty much it but and then and then he
tweeted out so Hassan's watching right
now he says you're lying okay how am I
okay let's should I call him should we
get him on the line yeah let's let's let
me open his stream and see what this
liar is doing because I'm on here dude
I've seen the Texas on I'm not quite
sure what to say in your defense because
it seems pretty clear-cut
what do you mean you were doing a q a at
Twitter by the way what does that mean
oh I did a like a question and answer at
Twitter they did like a thing where
people would Twitter headquarters yeah
in person yeah
wow did they pay for that no it was like
a
it was just like a thing that I that I
said I would do oh and it was fun was
that that was yeah that was after uh
Elon bought that mother it was yeah was
he he wasn't in attendance I'm assuming
no he wasn't there I was subconscious
yeah it was my sorry I'm opening
Hassan's
streaming with this idiot saying about
you
let's see you know because I was like
because I had to I did I did this like q
a thing at Twitter in the morning I was
like five times I'll go to your stream
after you know we'll hang out maybe like
an hour or something and then I'll and
I'll go meet everyone else can't wait
till his stream catches up so it'll be
another layer deep of reaction going
like tweets and it's like Curtis is
coming on the stream today and I was
like bruh I don't know if that's gonna
happen yet so it was like
wait what he literally wait he's
admitting it what what what
oh typical it's funny that he ghosted me
how am I
bro I saw the text all right I'm gonna
call him
I'm getting that slandered I'm getting
anything
if you need
if you need one I've been through a lot
of stuff like that damn I'm gonna get
his son on the phone
let's see if he answers
hey
hello okay so I hold on okay
I can hear you what's up wait why don't
you just call me like a normal person
off a Dan or something
oh you want we can do that you wanna you
can you call him I just DM Dan I just DM
okay we'll call you on uh Zoom or
whatever the [ __ ] or discharge Discord
Discord
yeah all right all right bye dude the
[ __ ] did you say call me like a
normal person on Discord yo if you play
cracker you can get him banned on Twitch
yeah if you play the sound yeah it's
crazy oh no I don't want to do that
that's crazy that would be we play that
sound by all the time when he's on and
right it's kind of nuts yeah that would
be crazy I don't want to be the the
reason that you know he gets taken down
again but all right so we're connecting
with Hassan and we'll get to that hello
okay there he is hello can you hear us
all wait I can't hear you for some weird
reason one second I'm just gonna fix
that real quick these twitch streamers
they get so butt hurt when you don't
hello can you hear me I use zoom we use
zoom it's better right and they go oh
Boomer [ __ ] yeah I still can't hear
you
is that us down or him if you're talking
I can't hear you I see your face moving
but I can't wait hold on let me
let me change the output to the okay and
now hey test
oh [ __ ] loud oh my God
okay
who's the Boomer now dude or not I'm
gonna turn off the camera on my stream
and turn it on on yours okay
we don't need to see you bro
oh oh wow I mean I'm just trying to
expedite this we're we're trying to do a
live you don't want to you don't want to
see my face
going on okay we got you we got you we
got here we go we got you
all right let's get to the bottom okay
there we go thank you for joining us
Hassan you know we we here at the H3
podcast we like their broker piece and
uh I think we could easily say that you
know Hassan represents Hamas and uh
Curtis I don't know your background but
let's say you're Israel
I'm just saying it's just an analogy
it's just an analogy
or I mean fine I'm fine with that yeah
yeah I'll work with that so so
um so there's a bit of a confusion here
now you both seem to think you ghosted
each other now Curtis showed me the text
he said yo he called you big dog
the tickets are at will call and you did
not respond what happened there Hassan
wait what when did he that's wait what
oh my gosh check okay on Instagram I
said I said that I got tickets for
you're on the list and then you said
when you in L.A oh
I didn't see it
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's crazy we had so many
conversations why didn't you why don't
you repeat it I don't I didn't think I
had to I thought wait where did you did
you pull did you pull this information
what from like eight months ago wait
where is it it's Instagram
what was the date this was on
October
oh wait sorry one sec October 25th now
if I could October 25th of what year
1998 yeah wait what do you mean now if I
can interject he did sent it from Italy
which was about 4 30 your time I'm
looking I see it on Israel yeah yeah
yo you sent this to me at 3 45 a.m I
didn't even see it I just dm'd you when
are you in LA and you said I get there
on Friday afternoon for my show I'm back
for the 31st and the second for
quotation here on the second and I said
yo like we had so many conversations why
did you just repeat it I didn't see it I
thought I think I had you don't have to
repeat stuff but there it is so no I
didn't know okay well that does make me
feel better okay so he didn't ghost you
but we had like we had like three days
of coffee yeah we did we literally got
like three days of combos about kissing
each other and stuff did you show them
that did anyone was there any dick
pictures exchanged I mean
not on Instagram but not on Instagram
yeah
you don't want to get a hat no you you
yeah there was there was a little bit of
miscommunication where you said like I'm
gonna come through I'm gonna pull up
yeah on on Tuesday and I I saw that as
like oh yeah I mean this guy is the
mayor of of K-Town you know what I mean
right he's the man of his word yeah
that's where you were a reputable Source
yeah well okay we'll we'll chalk we'll
chalk it up as a miscommunication on
both of our parts I guess yeah you guys
are you guys are even
two miscommunications we're gonna wipe
the sleigh clean yeah we believe in a
two-state solution or one state solution
and so on which one are we aiming for
we're doing a we're we're doing a one
state where uh we're we're linking up
and building okay Hassan Woods are I
mean that sounds like something Hamas
would say but uh but uh we'll go with it
well I mean I am I am Hamas after all
wait okay so
I I
but like you texted me we we texted each
other multiple times why didn't you just
bring that up I mean I just figured I
don't know I figured you were like if
you you mean like why didn't I bring up
that you didn't come to the show
yeah why didn't you just order like this
video right you know what you're like
you didn't want to come right it's
embarrassing you know I thought you're
my good friend and he was like oh I got
tickets for you it will call like you
didn't respond to that earlier or
something like oh [ __ ] it's all right I
figured you were you know a busy guy you
know it's it's fine dude yeah it's water
under the it's it's tears under the
bridge okay it's my tears under the
bridge this is madness this is actually
madness Okay we talked so much that is
true maybe I could okay next time I will
repeat myself like crazy I will I will
make sure right that you know right
where I'm at and what yeah at least
three times you say something it's an
invitation yeah he's like well known
he's like Beetlejuice wait what you you
literally you you ducked me like three
times how am I at fault no I wasn't
saying you're at fault
typical
in the middle easy why why is it always
this is what this man this is what this
man does he Ethan always is starting
drama is my expertise no bro I'm
immediate just keeps bringing he keeps
ringing more handsome men than me on a
show and then and then starting drama
for no reason we'll name one other
handsome man I've brought on the show
they're all been uh Jeff oh yeah Jeff is
one uh also uh Mike
Mike
I mean listen no offense to Mike but
what's up
I don't actually let me see if he's
handsome or what he's handsome for
six-year-old younger he's older young
gravy and you kissed him also Mike is
very handsome they just wanna yeah he's
handsome Curtis I wanted to ask and we
might as well do it while Hassan's on
the call would you be interested and
feel free to say no no pressure it's a
weird request but can I get a peck
what you're not doing this yeah just are
we cooking Hassan yeah yeah
[Laughter]
and like because I did this with young
gravy you don't have to like just
lipstick that's it yeah you don't even
have to Puck is that okay Gemma yeah
okay and thank you a thousand percent
yeah she's here Jen's here oh wait my
wife is unmute and say that I'm Mike
just so everybody uh yeah believes it
one thousand percent yeah there you go
we have consent from the wife all right
ready yeah here's a song
that's that's disgusting
um
[Music]
thanks bro good kiss man that's messed
up that's messed up I'm so glad that you
were here to see that Hassan wow this is
this is what Ethan is doing
oh my goodness all right well I'm sorry
I saw it next I'll have to do I'll come
back and do a show and I will it'll only
be your name on the list no tickets
just one for for me only yeah a one-man
show but it's you're it's a one-man in
the audience yeah I can't I can't
believe this I I just got cuck live on
camera it's like I'm on my sneaker
but you guys you guys can have plenty of
time behind the scenes to make out and
do whatever yeah I just want to do but
uh Hassan thanks for calling you know
there was a lot of bad feelings it seems
like between the two of you and I'm glad
we got it out in the open and we're able
to kind of just bury the hatchet and you
guys can move on with your friendship
and take it to the next level okay yeah
all right all right well have fun guys
have fun have fun kissing more
also whatever you guys are doing on the
HD podcast yes
all right
buddy love you buddy sorry bye loser
idiot
damn I love his son he's great great
good guys solo guy okay you know what I
like about Asana I like about you
there's not many men online who oh take
on openly the issue of misogyny online
yeah you're right and uh I love it I
love to see it yeah yeah there's a yeah
it's refreshing I like it I mean yeah
especially like
the last like year I feel like has been
especially like more so of being like
and people like
maybe it was that people were just being
more like silent about it before with of
being like you know and now people
they've sort of been like
you know like encouraged to be more like
[ __ ] like you know hate like hateful
I guess I don't know it's like Andrew
Tate and that [ __ ] guy or whatever
that's what I wonder too was like I I
wonder if it's part of like the whole
Maga movement because it it's somehow
for some reason misogyny
goes hand in hand with conservatism I
feel like all those guys are um
yeah yeah learning the same way right I
feel like a lot of them don't see women
as like a human human beings it's pretty
crazy
um I don't know it's it is pretty scary
dude I don't know
um and I feel like a lot of uh
I don't know if it's like baked into
like algorithms like purposely or
accidentally but I feel like it's get it
gets pushed out a lot
especially like young boys that's the
thing about Tate is we one of the we
talked about them a lot here but um one
of the things I always wondered is like
who's watching this and isn't having an
impact and then we started getting posts
from like teachers of really young men
being like uh talking of like horrible
things about women and saying Andrew
takes their hero and I was like wow
that's crazy yeah it is scary to think
about that there's that's even something
you can consume at that age because
man when I was back when I was a kid man
it was Pokemon you know
yeah
so you're a bit you're a bit younger
than me I'm old as [ __ ] bro you know how
old I am
32 oh you're so sweet I love that
everyone always says 50. wow I'm 37.
Jesus 15 37. that's not that bad they
always say 40 but yeah you're real age
40. right that's not that old I'm 37
stop it all right well you look 32 to me
so that's is that right yeah thanks bro
yeah 42 you guys upped it the [ __ ]
is that 37. the haircut really takes
five years it's youthful yeah yeah yeah
but I know what it is like uh I I
appreciated you were one I think one of
the first people to dunk on uh fresh and
fit and we've had a ongoing uh beef with
those guys too yeah they're [ __ ]
weirdos man such weirdos yeah
Ida
yeah they did like uh they did like a
response video to mine as well and I
didn't even like I didn't even watch it
because I just like I didn't want to I
know I literally already knew exactly
what it was going to be
um but well they always say to me you're
fat and your wife is ugly so right I
don't know it what do these guys tend to
say about you they'd call me like a soy
boy yeah yeah you know yeah like you
know like a beta right
um so beta getting married and having a
career yeah it's like what's beta being
happy and in love and you know doing
what you like it's pretty big loser beta
yeah yeah I'm just here and angry about
women all the time yeah my favorite
thing he goes is don't be sensitive
around women don't think you're a [ __ ]
don't ever open up just confiding your
boys only yeah that's a nightmare
my theory on these guys is that they
they all come from
very broken homes it literally okay in
my video I went I read his like
like three e book that he was giving out
to people
um and in the thing he was like
I forget the what actually happened but
like the story of like it was like his
he was like crying or something or being
sad or about something and then his dad
was like don't [ __ ] like men don't
cry you gotta [ __ ] it was literally like
and it was him being like and that
changed my life that set me on like the
up and up and it's like no that's a good
thing yeah it's like no that's abuse
that's the arc deep trauma yeah you
gotta like address that I think wow and
the hunch that I always have is that
it's like Father issues not Mom issues
right and I think the same thing when
you look at Andrew Tate his dad is like
uh
seems like a real [ __ ] crazy ass dude
he just I didn't think a guy like Andrew
Tate would even like have parents I feel
like he would like that he cared one day
yeah he does just born from a nut stuff
yeah yeah his his head kind of does look
like a one half of a nuts that's
interesting so my neck shaving nut yeah
a well-groomed nut well yeah and another
another funny thing smooth nut another
thing from Fitz uh ebook he goes another
transformative moment
was when someone in class squeezed his
tricep yeah that was it and called him
skinny yeah yeah and that like changed
his life [ __ ] that's all it took he was
so on
he was so on the edge yeah I think it's
I think the dads are causing the the
damage here and so what's his dad you
did like what's his dad like uh Tate
yeah well I've heard him talk about his
dad how he has kind of a similar
philosophy on life as him right his
dad's actually a professional chess
player but I think he abandoned the
family when he was young
to like yeah he was just like super into
chess and not into his sons right at all
foreign
but um
that's weird let me ask you this what's
your what are your parents like do your
parents like uh yeah my dad left to play
chess when I was a baby yeah oh [ __ ]
you're an anomaly then yeah
um no my pain my well like my uh my
parents split up when I was like super
young
um so I think I was like three
or four maybe when they divorced well
not they were never married they just
like split up uh my dad like moved away
um bought a bunch of chess boards
um
yeah and then it was just like my mom
for a like a little and then I had to
step dad I have a stepdad and like
pretty much ever since and he's like the
[ __ ] coolest dude ever so okay
um so are you in contact with your dad
yeah like I still talk to him like it's
not like a
I don't I see it maybe like at Christmas
you know and you guys don't talk you're
not very close with them would you say
I mean like no it's not like you know
like it's not like we're super you know
the best buddies I guess but you know
it's just I mean like it just happens
right like I'm I feel like there's a lot
of things where it's like
where I was like pretty bitter about
stuff and it's like you know
um and even like I was like sad about
stuff too that was happening but at the
same time it's like the older I got it's
like
you know
phones work like both ways you know so
it's like you know so that was the whole
thing and it's bones work both ways but
you expect a little bit more effort from
your dad for sure yeah you know like
kids shouldn't have to and attention
from their parents yeah it's supposed to
be right yeah that's what I was saying
like that's I like I could you know it
shouldn't it should be shouldn't be on
all the shouldn't be on the kids to be
like what's up Dad yeah because you're
like you know I don't know but my
stepdad's super cool he's great and my
mom's awesome that's good yeah that's
nice so your stepdad was kind of your
father figure growing up for sure yeah
did you have step siblings no no he uh I
just I have one a sister I have an older
sister half sister or full sister I have
one
full sister and then one half sister so
yeah same dad I see and how are you guys
close with your sisters yeah yeah nice
pretty close uh super close with my like
you know Kylie my sister
um and then my uh my half sister I'm
close with her as well
um yeah they were just at my show in
Buffalo that was really good according
to Goose oh yes
um
but yeah it's uh they're great I love my
sisters love my family and uh yeah it
was it's it's cool that it uh and it
took me like it was obviously like when
you're a kid and it's like
um you know you don't understand that
like you want that like you know your
biological dad for whatever reason
you're like we you know you're my dad
why aren't you like you know but you
know it's once it's the same as you know
you get older and you realize that like
if you know the person who was there
that that's you know that's your dad you
know yeah so you probably had some
resentment issues probably growing up
right for sure yeah yeah absolutely yeah
and there's I mean that's probably not
never gonna go away right I mean uh you
know I'm sure
you know a lot of people go through that
you know uh dads that don't do the the
best job right but you know it's the
same thing I I feel like I'm at the
point where it's like [ __ ] whatever
yeah I mean at a certain age what can
you do exactly yeah but it seems like I
wonder if having that like a good step
dad uh father role model kind of helped
you in so in a lot of ways because you
look at these
a lot of people who don't have a dad for
whatever reason these Alpha World guys
they end up so [ __ ] up now obviously
that's not like a a rule for everybody
right yeah but I wonder if having that
uh stepdad in your life yeah I mean for
sure it definitely shows that like you
know and he's and he's definitely like
he's like the most like
just like patient and like
like calm and just like just like like
just like level-headed dude like ever
like he's like and it was obviously that
I think I'd like to help that rubbed off
on me a little bit
um and he's always like very just like
caring and you know and um you know just
always very just making sure that
everyone is just like happy that's nice
that's awesome yeah he's like a good
dude yeah shout out Lawrence Lawrence
what the [ __ ] is oh let's go Warriors
let's go
yeah there should be like a there should
be like a service where step dads they
sort of go they could ship them out to
these guys that need that adopt the best
yeah step dad on demand well there's big
brother and sister of America maybe
Andrew Tate just needs a big brother
yeah a stepdad of America yeah
step brother you know what's my favorite
fact about fit by the way just a side
step back to that he did you know this
he's a [ __ ] fed he's a narc and the
craziest part is he used to work for who
did he work for was it Homeland Security
yeah Homeland Security and their human
trafficking Department which is real I
really was a [ __ ] fed bro and human
trafficking the man has Andrew Tate on
the human trafficker and he worked in
human trafficking we got him did he get
fired or I think he even got I don't
know about that bro no that's right I'm
narcotics
they take a little out of the uh out of
the evidence Locker yeah well fit was
trying to steal the goods the humans 100
made of
yeah that's all that's all a joke right
not even speculative it's just actually
um we gotta go to a break thank you
thank you Dan's been Dan's been blowing
me up
Discord uh thank you to our sponsor we
actually did a pre-roll because Ila's
super passionate about this one and so
she popped in before the show and we did
this so go ahead Dan uh uh roll our
sponsor and we'll be right back in a
couple minutes
thank you to our new sponsor very
excited to announce our partnership with
the ordinary ah this is one of the
coolest sponsors we've had in a while
Ela is a huge fan of this brand I am and
I was using them before this happened
and when I saw that they're joining as a
sponsor I just was so excited and I
wanted to be here for the read yes so
you have your whole arsenal of stuff you
use here yeah and what's cool about the
ordinary is they are off yet yeah can
you see Ila's arsenal of goods here
that's how she maintains that beautiful
complexion that the gorgeous glowing
skin yes work it work it so what's cool
about the ordinary is that they offering
like super high-end beauty products but
completely disrupting the market because
the prices are unbelievably affordable
like this niacinamide which is a serum
used to like shrink your pores and make
your skin look looked less shiny
is nine bucks
nine bucks I feel like something like
this would usually cost like I don't
know 50 bucks I mean the one that you
were talking about Ila is the uh are all
of the moisturizer
super high-end moisturizer
you I mean this is what you use on a
daily right maybe at night eight dollars
yeah and I've I've tried so many
different brands because I never know
what's the right one and I've spent all
kinds of money dude the price range of
the stuff is it can be insane yeah and
this feels like perfect on my skin and
it's only ten dollars dude that's all
that's a real good look at that face
that's a real endorsement
these are products that Ela uses the
ordinary my goodness the ordinary is the
most searched skin care brand in the
world and they're disrupting the Black
Friday Madness with their annual
slovember sale the ordinary is a line by
Beauty incubator decim of accessibly
priced effective clinical formulations
for skin hair and body
the web store their website and store
will be non-transactional on Black
Friday which I guess means they're not
selling anything on Black Friday to
avoid the rush and wasteful Panic buying
that flash sales like that can create so
instead they are presenting their
slovember sale what is slovember it is
the ordinary's annual 23 off sale that
runs throughout the entire month of
November except for Black Friday when
the website will be non-transactional
but the less but the entire rest of
November you're getting 23 off and these
prices are already so cheap kind of
incredible I think their margins aren't
that crazy where they can slice more
than that off
um the ordinary belief skin care
purchase should be made thoughtfully and
with intention that's why they're not
open on Black Friday
follow the at the ordinary and at Destin
on Instagram and Tick Tock all November
long for opportunities to learn directly
from the brand about the science and
skincare of their products and then shop
the sale to find your Perfect Skin Care
pairing there's no rush pressure or
impulse purchase necessary and when you
feel ready to shop check them out to
ordinary.com Lincoln bio for their world
famous science based skin care and a 23
off saving no code necessary all month
long baby it's still ordinary and decim
website and stores will be closed on
Black Friday but they're going to be
running a 24-hour live special called
slovember TV where you can meet their
team see their in-house labs and even
get more expert advice don't forget to
live and Shop slowly the ordinary will
be waiting for you what do you want to
say something specifically here so I
have been using their squalene cleanser
um and I love it because it also is a
makeup remover and and just a face
cleanser so I use it every day twice a
day morning and night and it doesn't dry
my skin the one thing the one thing I
really hate about flight face cleansers
is that after I use them my skin is gets
so dry and then it's like you feel like
you gotta hydrate and it's this whole
cycle
so this one feels my skin just feels
really clean afterwards and not dry
which I love and then the moisturizer
which we already talked about I'm trying
to find that uh oh here it is here's the
cleanser it's 15 bucks yeah that's a big
ass Bottle too that's another thing I've
been using these already I don't know
how long over a month right maybe two
months and you can see there's barely
even a dent in it oh dude you can get
the smaller bottle for six bucks
oh I mean look at this I've been using
it twice a day look it's still like you
got a lot in there still
that's awesome man I love companies like
this who come in and disrupt because
let's face it this industry is just it's
such a it's it's a lot you know I mean
people are over charging the [ __ ] out of
it and this is proof by by the ordinary
so we know also how I love a full
package when I buy I also buy with my
eyes and I love their packaging and I
just love how like it looks so simple
and clinical it looks like that's what I
want for my skin you know I want to feel
like somebody's in a lab just creating
the best thing to make my skin look
better preach so yeah we love the
ordinary I'm super we're we're all super
excited to be working with them so uh
the link is in the description guys
you're gonna get 23 off
uh all the month of November on their
slovember sale except for Black Friday
they're not selling but anyway thank you
so much and we are live what's up guys
welcome to fed him the ordinary
absolutely awesome thank you guys
what up people we are back
um yeah I was just telling you about uh
how fit is a [ __ ] fed here's a post
from his
here's a post from Instagram he goes
haters will say you're a rat
correction I control rats
I left the job to pursue podcasting but
it was good but I was good at what I did
um
human trafficking bro
Department didn't he also I think he
also said that in his like little book
that he was like a convicted felon as
well is he or that might be wrong I feel
like hold on let's do it next to that I
do there was like something where he was
about to he was like going down like a
bad path or something to like become
like a criminal or something and he
turned his life around or something what
does this mean cardio is that Spanish
what is that shirt
I'm trying
dude no way you you busted someone with
a thousand with 15 20s bro
this is the bust of a lifetime bro he
caught this guy with 200 bucks in a
passport too that's crazy like this
guy's passport
oh
keep it going
might everyone be like this when he hits
up a human trafficking
do you have your passports
[Music]
oh you know that I do [ __ ] awesome
it's crazy one of my favorite videos is
that a real song that he'd like just
like Freestyle you know we've debated
that
the consensus seems to be that he
improvised it wow I think they rehearsed
that [ __ ] and took it on the road right
did you get your shots
uh
Uganda or something or Nigeria so you
know you have to get
I mean I like that Ethiopia yes I was
taking the precautions you know but they
won't let him on the plane right you
know yeah the other one oh I closed it
out whatever [ __ ] crush and fit those
guys are so boring yeah and lame
but um anyway I'm glad you're doing the
good fight on that
that's that's good I love that about you
and so uh here let's move on we got
about an hour left so let's just move on
to some topical kind of fun goofy stuff
and get your
get your take on the pulse of culture
yeah all right
first of all I've actually been meaning
to talk about this Elon Musk eight
dollars a month for uh
Twitter verification yeah Elon Musk just
bought uh
Twitter
what's the Chinese guy who impersonates
Iran Musk
he's on Tick Tock and he looks just like
Elon Musk and that's his name on Tick
Tock it it's called Leon ma wait to link
me that [ __ ] bro have you seen this it's
so [ __ ] funny I haven't seen it Leon
Ma
it's so good uh in the meantime
eight dollars a month for a check mark
he says uh you will get priority and
replies
so that means you can pay to get like
top
reply this is yours truly mentions and
search
which is essential to defeat spam scam I
don't understand what he means by that
because if you're a scammer or spammer
then you would pay the eight dollars and
get to the top of search
yeah priority and replies mentions and
search which is essential to defeat yeah
what the [ __ ] how is that how is that
essential to Phoenix Pam but here's my
favorite you get half as many ads oh
that's nice
I love he's not willing to pledge no uh
for [ __ ] Twitter yeah those long
video yeah that's the one thing about
Twitter I can't post long audio that's
what I've been looking for man yeah I
need that long audio bro it seems kind
of insane to me actually Stephen King
had the best take he's like you should
be paying me to be on your [ __ ]
platform mm-hmm yeah like we're creating
content right yeah why the [ __ ] am I
paying
so yeah I don't get is it so you pay so
anybody can pay eight dollars anybody
but then does that mean you get a badge
like you get verified yes that's [ __ ]
weird wait is the whole point of the
verification is to improve the user
experience so that they know
that people are really who they are
right right yeah and so when you remove
that and just sell it
it seems like chaos it just seems to
defeat the whole purpose of the right
thing because like yeah now like
you know that's like
not anybody could just you know all the
like the losers that like I went to
school with this stuff yeah yeah I'm not
paying for that [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] not
yeah that's like the that's like the one
way to show like how big of a loser you
are right that's what I think I think
it's kind of a dunce cap situation and
you know what
it's gonna be interesting to see what
happens with this though I think it's
going to be a cluster [ __ ] I think
Twitter's gonna die what do you think
about that Dan you think Twitter's gonna
die because of this
me yeah uh and maybe not because of this
specifically but uh I mean he's been
throwing out a lot of ideas and they all
seem terrible so I don't know it it
might not be long for this world that's
so awesome yeah 44 billion did
it's [ __ ] awesome that's yeah good
good purchase for sure [ __ ] he's like
bro I could I could house every homeless
person in America or
I can make sure that my my that that
place where I like to [ __ ] post uh where
Nazis can post their no okay you don't
get it though it's half the ads that for
them is fire half the end that is a fire
hook up bro
but that's so funny I play like eight
dollars a month for like Hulu you have
to get a product yeah you get to like
watch a bunches
Bachelor Bachelorette Bachelor in
Paradise the list goes on you know
Housewives Orange County of New York 90
Day Fiance
happily ever after 90 days thousand
pound sisters
excuse
come on come on
I think it's a deep fake by the way I
was gonna ask like that
beautiful
a p e
it's an interesting
it's a really good defect though follow
me
fake you don't
yeah that's that's true there's one he
recently did that was going by okay yeah
you're right I think it's a deep fake
it's way too good I mean it's really
good one here this one is nine million
hi hi everyone
hi everyone
I love how it always seems like he has
no plan for the videos yeah
um
two years
wow
that is so awesome I wish Elon musk's
voice was that high
yeah there there that is for you so no
problem damn 40 how much was it
to buy Twitter how much eight bucks a
month well how much sorry 44 billion 44
billion okay yeah yeah
yeah it's a lot
you want to do a poll of the audience it
has to be deep thick damn there's no
shot that dude looks that much like him
yeah
uh moving on have you do you know about
Howie Mandel prolapse tick tock I've
seen the one that he posted oh you saw
it did he post more no the one no just
the one are you say like like it's his
thing now I don't know like yeah but did
you see it on Tick Tock or how did I
think I saw it on Twitter because he was
like trending and then someone posted
the video it's so good it's he's
actually coming on next week we're gonna
get to the bottom of this and we have a
oh my God
dude we got the best [ __ ] lined up for
house it's gonna be so fun
you got like a real a live prolapse anus
for him you're gonna show him or
something
[Applause]
kind of
I do okay
I want to scare them off but we do have
we have a fire episode lined up I'll
just say that damn I called it
um well I wanted to show can you we made
a safe for work version can you pull it
up
I wanna
oh it doesn't work
we have some technical issue it sounds
like what do we do about it what are we
gonna do about it
how could you possibly make that safer
work I want that's it I wanted we did a
really good thing damn can is there any
way we can work with what we've got here
why don't we just show it [ __ ] just
bring it up yeah let's
what the [ __ ] it's upside down and yeah
it's just over I say it's okay yeah
pretty disgusting it's pretty safe for
work yeah it's very safe for work if it
was 9x16 it probably stretched it to
fill the screen stretched it like a
prolapsing aim yeah stretch it oh
uh boom okay here let me I've been
meaning to do this Tick Tock account we
love I love getting deep into Tick Tock
and finding the weirdest [ __ ] oh yeah we
found a new one I've been waiting for
someone good to share this with so I'm
glad you're here he's called life and
scars
and this man just lays it out
the real deal here like this one is how
to drive drunk whoa okay I got a dry
drunk look guys we already know your
dumb ass shouldn't be driving drunk but
you're a grown ass man and you gonna do
what the [ __ ] you want to do so me
telling you ain't gonna really help you
so if you're gonna do this [ __ ] listen
up
um I need you to take a piss that's the
first thing you need to do before you
leave I need you to take a piss try to
get as much of that alcohol out of your
system as possible what that's not how
it works how that works at all at all
bro
yeah
call this number he had 90k followers
two weeks ago and I was at 226k yo he's
the wife advice
all the drunk drivers of tick-tock
really
oh this is really bad advice though it's
kind of awesome I want to see what else
he uh I also need you to get a water or
coffee coffee would be better because
you're trying to get a little energy in
your system
um
I need you to put on your seat belt and
I need you to turn on the headlights if
you forget those two things you're
holding I can go to [ __ ] yeah I'm pretty
sure you're supposed to do those
regardless yeah he's just explaining how
to you could probably just get put the
drunk out of there just how to drive
it's true first thing you put the key in
there and then you go what I need you to
do is stay within the the line
before you turn there's a little thing
that you do absolutely stay under the
speed limit
pull it over by the police
now on the ride home I need you to roll
the windows down if you got a
convertible I need you to let the top
down that's kind of a wild advice it's
like 3 A.M
with all the windows down head out the
window it's super suspicious yeah
holy [ __ ] just so that everyone driving
by can get a good look at your drunk ass
oh this is good how cold or hot it is I
need you to turn the radio up and I need
you to snap that I don't care how cold
it is like minus 20.
dude that's oh that's so funny bro I
love it
I'm constantly we trying to increase
awareness here and uh step number five I
need you to know that even if you do all
this [ __ ] correctly your ass could still
die
true yeah I mean it's not wrong that's I
mean what do we think about this it's
like you're gonna do this
so here I mean it's bad advice granted
but like assuming it's good advice do we
like it do we like it in theory I mean
no I don't think so I think in theory
and in practice I don't think you should
ever have advice for a drunk driver
right here's what I need you guys to do
if you see a red light I want you to
stop it
I know it sounds crazy I know you want
to get home but stop stop it's harm
reduction yeah there's a theory harm
reduction right yeah hmm
you can't decide if I like it or not
here's another one how to smash an ugly
woman
if you see an ugly woman in the
crosswalk I'm gonna need you to speed up
wow I'm excited to hear this
okay
I would imagine it's pretty much the
same way uh
the looks here
spam and you gonna do something late at
night and I'm gonna tell you how it's
gonna go try to get in touch with the
cute chick and all of them either gonna
be flaky or you just won't have access
to them this is when all the ugly
[ __ ] start to look a little bit more
average like I said we've all been there
no shame step number one be discreet
don't let your friends know wow and damn
sure don't let other [ __ ] see you
with a bus that's so [ __ ] awesome wow
don't let anybody know you're [ __ ] an
ugly [ __ ] make sure you pee before
dude that turn off all your cameras in
your room that you usually use to record
yourself having sex also also it's crazy
that the thing was how to smash an ugly
woman right there but then he's and then
it somehow got worse pretty started yeah
no [ __ ] ugly [ __ ] Jesus man yeah I
see this stuff and I I just wonder
sometimes like how is it that uh
how is it that woman ever even like
touch or interact with men at all yeah
like what the f as if that's a real
person that is just like
that's crazy it's a lot it's actually
I'm finding
and I think the Andrew Tate fresh and
fit phenomenon is showing that there's a
lot of dudes who are
tired of uh women in the workforce right
whatever I don't know
they got too many rights
we need women back in the kitchen damn
it
that's so crazy [ __ ]
cause they gonna think that that's what
you deserve all right step number two
get drunk
a lot less uglier and drive there
how about just like don't have forced
yourself to have sex with people you
don't want to just jerk off dude just
wait yeah
you can do that while you're driving
it's not right
YouTuber and if you're driving to a fat
bitch's house you can jerk off on the
way and change your mind
holy [ __ ] Jesus guys demand
up in our draws they face quench up and
if you if a ugly [ __ ] start to look
uglier that's counterintuitive to you
busting the nut so it's almost like
having a Snapchat filter in your eyes
number three that's for real do
something new you're gonna have this
trauma in your head for weeks to months
after this she gotta pay for that unlock
a new sex move
she's gotta pay for that what does that
mean I don't know he wants to unlock a
new sex move
maybe it's like a like a sad crying is
there possible that this dude is joking
I I really hope so but also at the same
time this is a crazy thing to joke about
like to be this high level of like
satire it seems real to me yeah wait you
think he's joking Dan I think so he's
seen or at least he's trying to be funny
while like I don't know maybe it's like
50 50 things an ounce of like
self-awareness there it seems like like
a video diary like he did these things
so now he's like if you guys want to do
it too
right he's learned along the way yeah
this is the awesome thing I did if you
want to [ __ ] a fat
ugly [ __ ] imma need to get blackout
drunk just don't do it yeah just don't
do it you don't have to have sex with
people you're not attractive
okay this one this one's a little while
let's see maybe this one will reveal
perfect sized dick tell me about it bro
so you think you got the perfect size
dick but let's talk about it because
women tell you all day long their size
don't matter
the [ __ ] lie because the New York
Post asked them the same question
and uh they gave him a truthful answer
fellas and New York Post huh yeah we got
some reputable people on the ground
doing me picture
okay the dick is what you need for the
average woman to have an orgasm
moment of silence for little wee wee
game
now with that being said if you ain't
packing anything is fine because [ __ ]
is adjustable it works with you
um
so let's say you got a woman who can't
take no dick at all and she get with a
dude who's got like a 12 inch meat
missile well damn over the course of
[ __ ] hurt she'll be able to take that
dick he's gonna stretch her out within a
matter of weeks a month if he's a nice
guy and she'll be able to take all that
dick eventually now let's say she left
that guy and she got with somebody who
was packing five inches this guy's like
a penis scientist yeah it's the
conductor he's the Penis Professor he's
in the laboratory uh stretching and
loosening mock vaginas
that's well why he's [ __ ] her he's
leaving seven inches worth of [ __ ] on
the table once the [ __ ] found out he
ain't no threat it'll go back to the
factory settings and fit him well
oh so you think
so he's saying if a girl sleeps with a
large endowed guy it'll go back to
normal right yeah so that's that's
that's great right that's great news
factories
in fact I reset and learning so much
about
vaginas he didn't actually say the
perfect size though yeah that's what I'm
trying yeah I'd like to
hmm yeah he started with with youth oh
you oh you think you got the perfect
size
wiener
the way he was kind of being like yo you
you should be
like the vagina will shoot your dick so
it's kind of good news for everyone it
sounds like right yeah so that's that's
fine it's not very girthy
yeah that could be a problem
uh but yeah heads down for little PP
gang that one maybe he reveals more of a
yeah okay this one's really [ __ ] up
how to record yourself [ __ ] oh boy
this is actually this is like super
illegal bro oh man oh man this is
actually like a felony but okay
uh if this is what you want to put on
the internet let's hear it you'll see
I'm [ __ ] well I got you covered step
number one get consent don't be doing
those things okay
wait hold on before we clap too much
this next line could be like but if you
don't but if you can't get consent then
it's fine get it
number two make sure you record the
foreplay I'm talking about before the
clothes even come off look back on this
tape and you gonna thank me for this all
right step number three you need to
figure out how you're gonna record this
[ __ ] it's two ways to do it step number
one is the Hands-On approach that's when
you holding the phone and you're
recording everything yourself you get
good close-ups this way you get dick
veins [ __ ] lips facial expressions you
name it and that's a man you should be
able to record in every single position
except for missionary because your hands
on the bed and while you're eating some
[ __ ] tag this [ __ ] in make her do some
work or you got the other way to record
that's when you prop the phone up on the
dresser with this step don't move too
far to the left don't move too far to
the right you got a [ __ ] in front of the
frame but you get full body views all
right with that being said get out there
Quentin Tarantino a [ __ ] oh my God damn
okay this is pretty wild
I mean that was the most normal one yeah
kind of yeah it took me for a growth the
first man's account is like that tweet
that's like what women call an intrusive
thought a man calls an idea yeah
literally what his whole account
the first thing I want you to do is find
the record button you're gonna need that
to start filming
sure you passed before somebody called
him the modern Library of Alexandria
holy [ __ ]
That's crazy dude this guy ah how to
smash big girls and pregnant women
let's go Kings big girls and pregnant
women look I don't speak for high value
meals over here I just speak for the
average dude and it's gonna come a time
when our top priorities they're just
gonna be unavailable and we're gonna
have to settle and so when you come
across this situation I want you to I
want to let you know how you can make it
the most comfortable for both of y'all
big girls pregnant chicks they like to
be [ __ ] like this you lay them on
their side and you go ahead and lift
that top leg up push the knee towards
the stomach be careful especially with
the pregnant chicks you ain't trying to
need a [ __ ] baby in the head after
you do that you straddle that bottom leg
that's on the bed I need a knee on both
sides boom boom you get on top of that
[ __ ] push the ass cheek up and you go
into town on that [ __ ] now some
of the big girls they like doggy however
they don't like holding themselves up or
pregnant chicks because gravity ain't so
nice today or upper torso unless now you
could throw a pillow under that [ __ ] and
then it'll work out better for them look
don't act like you're too good for
nobody sometimes life hands you limits
sometimes it has you Water Management
so he's like settling that's what he
said at the beginning like you don't you
can settle for a pregnant a woman who's
like yeah creating a child yeah yeah you
know what's really interesting he's kind
of like a straight Dr Ruth you remember
Dr Ruth no I don't know he was like this
little German lady who was like all
about sex positivity and like teaching
people about sex in the 90s uh he's kind
of doing a pub is he kind of doing a
public service except for like the you
know to driving drunk and the [ __ ]
ugly jokes
Dr Ruth yeah yeah dude this woman was
teaching everyone about sex in the 90s
got some Infamous Stern moments too that
woman she was a queen yeah
can you imagine her just getting weird
and wild that's wild I love that for her
though I've never even heard of her yeah
here let's let's do a couple more how to
sneak out the house look sometimes when
you're living with somebody you might
want to sneak out for what reason I
really don't give a [ __ ] I'm just here
to tell you how to do it so first things
first if they got a ring doorbell it can
complicate things and in that case you
might want to use a window and in that
case you might want to pre-plan your
sneak out you do this by go ahead and
removing the window screen earlier that
day and finding out where your
floorboard creaks earlier that day it'll
save you from making a lot of noise at
night time and for you to make it move
now the second method is if you land
with your woman or something
oh God damn it
how to sneak out the house look
sometimes when you're living with
somebody you might wait till you hit a
heavy breathing and snoring and then I
need you to turn on rain sounds or white
noise it's night night [ __ ] she ain't
getting enough for hours and it's gonna
match the noise that you make when you
leave in the house now this last method
is for people wake up and there's just
White Noise for no reason that's totally
normal
that's normal
people who stay with their parents and
whatever
um go downstairs in the middle of the
night almost every night and get you a
snack or a drink they'll check up on you
at first but after a while they'll stop
and then you strike yo
kind of good advice he's thought of it
he's thought of everything man also what
that one comment says how do you find
parties in your city wait what the [ __ ]
that's sad he's looking for some more
he's actually looking for advice yeah
damn the through friends social media so
this is actually it's really nice people
coming together yeah the nice Community
he's really built actually yeah how do
you sneak in oh oh [ __ ] that's a little
dark yeah that's tough we don't like
that one as much
there's uh let's see the hamburger
whatever the [ __ ] that means has 1.2
hamburger I wonder where this is going
man I have no way
how to eat a hamburger
oh [ __ ] head oh my God this is just
endless
it's not playing bro I need to know how
to eat a [ __ ] hamburger help me bro
do the hamburger with your dick in your
balls
wait what the [ __ ] is that is he like a
meat sandwich with your dick okay
someone out there that's useful for it
listen up guys I require you to be in a
relaxed State you
didn't need to solve
that's your fingertips grab your right
nut grab your left nut boom boom after
that you're gonna keep your dick in the
middle throw that [ __ ] down with your
index finger whoa keep it folded now
when she done those three steps I need
you to rotate the whole [ __ ] unit
whoa oh my God at this point you should
have one ball on top Let's do an origami
with this [ __ ] and then one ball on
the bottom it's gonna resemble a
hamburger after that it's time to go and
press whoever you [ __ ] with
[Laughter]
hey we're going into 2023 different game
is game yeah how to do that all right
this guy's joking but holy that's great
I was not expecting I'm gonna show I'm
gonna show Eli I got a new trick tonight
wow the hamburger wow okay yeah he's got
some good advice you know
let me see let me find one more make it
big or are we looking for
uh how to smash yo girl Mama that says
bird bath
bird bath is that that's when you wash
your dick in the sink I think uh okay
wait where do you a bird bath yeah how
to do the burnt man with your ball set
oh we ain't got a lot of moves that we
can do with our nuts
you're right this one down
um if you've been doing the Batwing that
I told you about then oh we're behind a
nice pair of stretchy nuts nut stitches
with so first first things first is
practice I need you to get in the shower
and pour your nutsack out away from your
skin yeah this guy is in the [ __ ] and
ball
hamburgers and Batman
Frozen
stop calling me that holy [ __ ]
how to wear a dick how to wear a [ __ ]
and ball cage
using your thumb and your middle finger
okay don't grab actual testicle your ass
gonna be out for the season
out away from your skin using your thumb
and your middle finger I need you to
reach back with the index finger well I
gotta be honest there's a lot of advice
for ball mutilation yeah how to beat
this [ __ ] out of your own dick and ball
musty nuts whoa 2.5 million holy [ __ ]
this is why your balls stink your balls
think because a lot of y'all stay in hot
regions or y'all be working out and
y'all don't be watching y'all [ __ ] twice
a day I want you to reach down right now
with a finger rub your nuts dude every
video comes down here I mean you're not
he's gonna say do a snap test on your
nuts I guarantee it yeah smell it oh
yeah but ask yourself are you happy no
so listen to me if y'all do living in
high regions and y'all working out I
need you to take a shower at least twice
a day all right yeah if you're doing
that and it still stink you probably
need to trim All You hairy dudes y'all
do you but you know when you got hairy
nuts and [ __ ] that odor and the bacteria
it gets trapped up in there it takes a
lot more care to get rid of also use
ball deodorant use Gold Bond foot powder
put that [ __ ] on there give it a nice
little minty smell okay that ain't
working you could try give me your nuts
and vinegar wow
that's not gonna smell good at all nuts
and vinegar I'm gonna smell like a it's
gonna smell like nuts and vinegar I
think well there it is life and scars
lots of important life advice there for
you guys
wait how to get a woman if you're short
this seems this is I gotta see this yeah
gotta get some push
push short dude
why do we [ __ ] ugly [ __ ] cause the
opportunity and lack of options and um
you're gonna have to kind of put
yourself in that position sometimes so
the first thing I suggest you do is
become friends with a woman cold
approaches I don't think work as well
for short dudes especially if you're
approaching a woman it's holiday is it
advice is friend zone yourself yeah
that's pretty beta I think
the next step after that I shoot up at
school basically
I mean funds on the shooting of the
school is basically one straight line
what the hell where I come from
more than you she don't know your
personality become friends show your
personality went on her to feel
vulnerable and then strike in for the
kill whoa Jesus another way you can do
this wait did he stay with alcohol wait
a good go back
sometimes he goes a little too he snaps
off a little too hard yeah a little bit
for the kill maybe over alcohol yeah
competition game become friends with the
woman and then show her all these
pictures of all these other women that
you're dating even though you're not
that look better than her and tell them
how much them women enjoy you and how
much they appreciate the fact that
you're short it'll put a dot in her head
making her thinking
no no these are all the girls I'm dating
they love me that's like a George
Costanza [ __ ] yeah actually George
Costanza there was an episode where he
walked around with a picture of a
beautiful girl in his wallet and told
everyone it was his wife or his wife
that died and it worked for him so yeah
which is kind of an interesting modern
day uh George Christie yeah yeah yeah I
mean oddly except for like drunk driving
stuff and the ugly chick stuff he this
guy's kind of giving better life advice
than Andrew Tate I feel like yeah you
know there's obviously a few Exceptions
there that are pretty crazy but I mean
it's probably it goes from he covers it
all from ball torture to drunk driving
that's the game that's the game
yeah holy [ __ ] there it is guys uh loved
that for him learned a lot I also have a
bunch of videos here actually let's see
here
um
golly actually I've been wanting to
watch this video this lady
seen there oh dude okay the first like
30 seconds and then I stopped because I
could it's hard because I couldn't get
through it so there's that one point she
starts talking about like race and then
it gets good okay so you didn't even get
nothing after that part that's when it
got really hard oh man apparently it's a
it's a couple uh Ones white one's black
okay and uh it gets pretty wild uh
anything like this happening you guys
wedding any speeches like this yeah no
just good yeah it's good no racism it
was great okay yeah
oh my God okay I can't wait
hi I'm Shannon I've known Tracy for
oh God
I think
here's how you do the hamburger with
your dick and ball
I got some really good advice for all
everyone watching
how to make a taco out of your vagina
everybody listen up get your notes out
oh [ __ ]
Anthony
but
non-stop
seriously and she'd be like I mean that
I'm like I don't care I'm just kidding
it seems like a bit almost like it's so
bad yeah it's like an Amy Schumer bit
and I'm not you know I'm just she looks
a little whatever
I'm just saying right making
observations here I know what you mean
yeah you guys are so cute together
yeah
I swear to God you guys Our Hope
the longest seriously like tell death to
his party like seriously you better take
care of my girl because if you don't
yeah this is where I stopped watching
yeah this is when it goes really off the
road okay great yeah
just kidding
um
but yeah you guys are so cute like
you're a part of the families you're God
like
I'm not going to be racist you guys
you can hear people in the audience oh
my God
dude that's such a wild Segway
whoa I'm not gonna be racist you guys
I'm just saying I would but I'm not
gonna be I'll I'll bite my tongue I
guess oh [ __ ] Jesus Christ
okay
whoa you were just racist
of course you guys are going to get the
like interracial cups no seriously you
guys are whoa whoa whoa whoa what did
she just say something about interracial
couples I think I'm just kidding just
kidding just get um of course you guys
are gonna get the like interracial cups
where do they live
it's like you got I just want to let you
guys know you're gonna get a lot of [ __ ]
is that what she said yeah people are
gonna gasp because you're an interracial
couple what the [ __ ]
yo where is this you this got to be one
of those good old States boy oh wait
down here in Louisiana we don't prove no
mixed couple weddings
[Music]
yeah for me from that dress you probably
tell it's up to me I'd make mix
weddings illegal
yes sir
but it's a it's your wedding so I'll be
nice today
thank you so much for not being racist
up there it seems a lot so [ __ ] wild
seriously you guys are out stepping the
same time I love it
but you guys I swear I love
you guys are cool
she wasn't racist she said she loves
black people
oh my gosh like how did it get from I
love you guys to that I love black
people just for the record
huge fan by the way love what you guys
do with the all your stuff Jesus
I love that somebody recorded this and
put her on block
they had to wow but you guys I swear I
love
because some guys are the boobs
my daughter's great aunt is like the
best woman I know a black woman who's
really nice
yeah you can tell she definitely lost
the crowd oh why oh yeah they're they're
and she keeps going I once met one black
woman who was really not I love black
women
oh my God
bless you
yeah and you're like wrap it up
holy [ __ ] dude I'd love to be see what
happened in the aftermath yeah because
the thing about yeah that you do
speeches at a wedding and then there's
like another there's another like two or
three hours after that oh yeah that's
just usually the very beginning that's
probably the worst name wait there's
more uh what is this page this is the
original page that posted it
um there's just some other so you get
more context yeah I mean there's the
bride and groom right there on the top
right two at 11 million her life was
kind of [ __ ]
cringe warning she shows the bride's
response in that second video the text
messages
this one
this one this one yeah
what was your reaction to the speech
people are asking on tick tock
when she started going up there I kind
of froze up and was holding Anthony's
hand once she got to the mixing part I
dug my nails into his palms immediately
look toward the family and gave Ty that
light get her
that light get her look that light get
her look so she knew this woman was I
think sounds like I don't know
let's see if I think there's more or no
that's it that's it they really gave us
a long time to read it one that's it
that's all you guys talked about it
yeah that was crazy I see her in this
one there she is
oh
I figured she she would have been one
she really went for it
so they let her stay huh
there it is that's one of the cringiest
videos I've seen in a vlog oh yeah that
made me that made my [ __ ] skin crawl
I hate that yeah actually um it turns
out they're uh on Truth social is uh
queuing up to give her own podcast
yeah
Rumble gave her an exclusive contract
after that video dropped so it's good
happy for her oh my God okay I actually
okay so here's another one I want to get
your opinion on you guys you know this
guy Daniel Mack he's the what or what do
you do for a living yeah yeah yeah he's
awesome
he's so cool so this one goes Super
sideways and it went incredibly viral I
mean it has 1.1 million likes damn which
means like it's got 10 million views
right
tell me what you think about this okay
I'm gonna play it and then let's see hey
your car is awesome what do you do for a
living
Sorry I filmed videos where I ask people
on Tick Tock but they do a nice cars
walk up to people and start filming that
yeah uh I mean I don't know I've
literally I'm just asking a question I
just like your car
I it's what my whole account is but
we're here
a question
oh my gosh oh you're gonna get out
pepper spray over really okay this is
just dude
oh my gosh okay so what's really
interesting about this is that Jesus
Ellie is wild oh my god oh that's what
he looks like yeah yeah
I'd be pretty taken it back too most of
the comments are like wow she's such a
[ __ ]
Karen's in person blah blah blah uh
but but my honestly my opinion is like
she they're kind of right yeah like if
you run for sure with your phone in
their face yeah what do you do for a
living what do you do it's insane yeah
and like I would hate you should know
that what he's doing is insane I also
think this might be fake that's my
theory a lot of his videos are
definitely set up yeah I feel like this
is a a thing to sort of go viral but the
thing is is that if that's the case then
these women
are like going to be known as like these
psycho [ __ ] like people are going to
recognize them right
yeah I don't and there's no like info
about it it could be fake though it
certainly could be yeah I always hate
the it's it's so annoying when he's like
I've seen some of his videos where he
like goes up to like the oldest guy ever
and it's like what do you do for a
living they're like you're the guy on
Tick Tock those are fake yeah it's like
no way you [ __ ] know and then they go
they go why don't you come to my house
yeah yeah so why don't you move in man
but
this man has asked the president himself
and he was even more respectful they
don't owe you an interview okay so some
people yeah excuse me hi your car is
awesome it is a he goes like right to
100 that's the thing it's not like hey
can I film if this was real yeah I feel
like the right way to do it would be
like hey what's can I you guys mind if I
yeah but then the camera's rolling in
their face I probably react to
in a similar way and also being like you
know young women
yeah Targets in a car nice car like that
right yeah like who knows like what dude
there's nothing scarier than like
young white men a group of young white
men in my experience [ __ ] pop
off they're scary man so I'm I'm team
them honestly yeah
Karen bro that's [ __ ] up
that's [ __ ] up I think he's a Ken is
that what we do again for guys can yeah
like a man Karen did we decide on that
that's right did we ever come to a
conclusion
I don't know Ken
I think he's like Kevin okay oh okay
Kevin yeah I think it was a while ago
that we talked about this but
wait was this the same guy I like your
Louis Vuitton bag no it's a different
guy I see yeah that's that's our sound
guy Zach and his girlfriend got hit up
that was for real that was completely
real this [ __ ] just put his
phone right in our face okay what do you
guys do exactly
it almost it does seem fake in a way so
I wouldn't know right yeah he's like
Louis Vuitton bag it's like [ __ ] you
guys you know it's like leave me alone
there it is okay there we we've resolved
this uh Daniel Mack is indeed the Kevin
and uh let it be known
yeah we've had the me and Jenna have
this working theory on Kevin's oh yeah a
good one is very hard to find like a lot
of Kevin's that I've pretty much most
the Kevin's we know are like have turned
out to be like bad people Oh you mean
just straight up all oh real Kevin's
like guys named Kevin yeah oh do you
know really I know I have two really
good friends named Kevin so no [ __ ] okay
that's disappointing to you probably
well you gotta drop them I know I'm just
wondering what their dark secret is now
I don't think I know for everyone named
Kevin in my whole life that's that's
pretty good yeah I keep I tend to nice
keep toxic people out of here yeah
you're a good judge of character or
Kevin's watching right now yeah
hello Kevin made your name idiot
Heaven I what's the one uh
Kevin Spacey yeah he wow that's not good
well Kevin Bacon is kind of a Vibe so
Bacon's pretty epic too well there it is
that's bacon it cancels out epic Pizza
Kevin Hart
Ford
just a show note okay yeah
you know about this uh Ryan Kavanaugh
guy he was suing me I I remember that
yeah he's suing me four times jeez and
uh he owns triller and they advertise
the Kevin Hart was on it in the
description and that was determined to
be a lie Kevin Hart is not on the app
they had to change the description so
it's pretty such a weird thing to lie
about yeah yeah no I agree so specific
celebrity to say that you're gonna be on
there no and he's a [ __ ] liar I mean
for for example one time Ryan Kavanaugh
he used to own a business relativity
media huge production company right he
bankrupted it because he's an
incompetent loser but as it was
bankrupting he had a president
that worked there at the time and he had
this huge um golden parachute right like
if to fire him he had to get a huge
Severance except for misconduct so what
Ryan Cavanaugh does is he fabricated a
note from as if it was written from HR
saying that he was accused of sexually
harassing employees and and literally
lied about that so he could fire him
without Severance and even a judge who
adjudicated it right then I'm right on
point with this he said that she
believes Ryan Kavanaugh wrote it himself
the HR person said she never heard of it
and the last person to edit the note
upon forensic analysis cave wow
oh
he's known as Kevin on now [ __ ]
whoa there we go actually I don't know
if you know this but we made a website
uh if you go to Google and type Ryan
Kavanaugh which I encourage everyone to
do
you'll go to the search result and just
go down a little bit and uh thank you
it's dropped a little bit in the ranking
we used to be number one but does rank
having to look like Harvey Weinstein if
you guys want to learn more he actually
owes me 61 000 because he was ordered to
pay the first uh legal lawsuit we won
he's already paid my attorney fees so
we're waiting on that
but uh does he look like uh Harvey
Weinstein that's the question the public
confused and uh well you tell me uh what
what do you think I mean yeah
there's a resemblance right yeah yeah
the public is confused it's like if you
put him in a microwave for a little bit
he'll microwave
just just a little I mean look at that
it's like it's like crazy yeah and then
you know there's just kind of like if
you scroll down a little bit uh you
actually here's a picture of him kissing
uh Harvey Weinstein which is interesting
do you see it but the reason the reason
the reason we put them together is of
course to teach people that they are
indeed different people right because
there is confusion about that right and
uh if you scroll down you can kind of
just learn about him for example he's
gotten DUIs
uh which is super interesting yeah he
was arrested for drunk driving speeding
and driving with a suspended license
that sounds really bad you should have
watched [ __ ] that guy's video bro there
we go actually it's even worse he got
you got he was arrested for driving with
a suspended license from an earlier DUI
I mean this guy just doesn't learn his
election too much wine sorry lying under
oath that's the story I told you about
he didn't roll his windows down he was
accused of running a Ponzi scheme by his
partner which was later uh he retracted
it but he was accused right uh without
and he he also didn't pay his uh
babysitter 175 thousand dollars yep he's
being sued by her and uh the Ponzi
scheme by the way it was retracted I
just want to make that clear right
that's something he's suing me for
also he he threatens his critics I mean
he sent me this DM
uh which I'm not going to read to you
because I've read it a thousand times
but and actually uh this is important
Harvey Weinstein is praising Ryan
Kavanaugh here here and that is Ryan
Cavanaugh is a force of Nature and I
mean if I'm not sure that's an
endorsement you want right no that's
probably the last guy you want to see
yeah also something interesting
he promised a million dollars to Habitat
to humanity they have this whole big
ceremony for him and then he [ __ ]
didn't give them the money bro look at
this and now from one incredible partner
um to the next I have an amazing
announcement to share with all of you
tonight
because of all your hard work during the
Jimmy Carter work project and all of the
media that came out to cover our hard
work you have inspired an angel donor to
come forward this week I'm thrilled to
announce that we're building a Greater
Los Angeles campaign has its first one
million dollar donation from an
individual wow no way Kevin
this gentleman is Mr Robin Kavanaugh
only is Ryan giving us one million
dollars but he has agreed to be the
chair of the campaign Ryan will join our
honorary co-chairs mayor and Tony yes so
he's really good at accepting the praise
but not actually executing the promise
uh well yeah it's still a million bucks
man you don't wanna
that's a lot it says well there's a
discrepancy between right he brought out
an oversized check bro and then the
actual check he gave them was 35 000. 35
000 from a million
wow and this is all yeah this is all
legit so that's right Kavanaugh the guy
who's suing me and uh this website is
just again so you can tell the
difference between him
and Harvey Weinstein and I just want to
bring you up to that so if you guys want
to check that out and the best way to
find it is to type his name into the
search bar
right and then go back a little bit
because yeah it's right there right
there thank you thanks for your time
that's great oh can I show you his
LinkedIn dude it's so funny and now that
I'm on it there's a few uh Ryan
Kavanaugh updates I've been wanting to
share this is his LinkedIn profile this
guy owns triller he's a big ass [ __ ]
media Mogul look at his about my
Wikipedia page has been hacked taken
over by paid editor thrust so for now
the uh that the accurate Wookie can be
found here this guy he has this
conspiracy theory that this guy throws
that we're banking the edit his
Wikipedia I'm telling the Lord with Ryan
Cavanaugh is [ __ ] awesome that's new
that's not how Wikipedia works no a
hacker like it's not yeah anyone can
anyone can just anyway he's awesome
actually he didn't he he talked about my
band too sorry to bring this up uh uh
but here he said this about me
uh but then again at YouTube I love how
he asks YouTube like they're going to
see that [ __ ] on Instagram
you could see it let people post
statements about hoping certain people
die in the next uh let's skip all that
and they only get a one week suspension
I won't say his name because every time
I do my entire family gets hundreds of
death threats come on bro that's not
true no yeah including that they're
coming after my children stop it Ryan
another hate message is on Insta but I
think most people know who I'm referring
to I don't know I don't know maybe roast
yeah probably thrust anyway we don't
have Public Enemy Number One thank you
but Thrift oh he messaged love our
editor or one of our editors he messaged
him on on uh
I thought the first one was a message
him just saying trailer yeah I think
that's like his his job title oh yeah he
said nice to finally meet and then in
parentheses find you perhaps we should
talk gross
a super weird bro he's such a weirdo
nice to find you yeah so anyway there's
there's a lot of lore there but I'm not
gonna put that all in you
that's crazy yeah so but we have about
10 minutes left I know you guys uh are
you guys are going to catch a flight
yeah we got to go to Portland tonight we
got to do a show we have a show tomorrow
in Portland but we're flying there
tonight and you guys have what three
more shows you said uh three uh three
more cities four more shows we have two
shows in Seattle the day after Portland
so so you do two shows sometimes when
the first one when the first one sells
out we had the second one that's awesome
and then you guys are basically home to
Canada
are you are you Canadian too
oh wow both Canadian that's [ __ ]
crazy that's [ __ ] up man have you ever
lived here no United States no no I
never once really no interest no there
was a time where we like kind of were
thinking about it but then we thought
about it for longer yeah
we were thinking about it than we
thought about it no no I feel that
excited against it this country's
[ __ ] crazy especially in the last
five years it's [ __ ] scary yeah I'm
making my escape plan to move to New
Zealand when uh that's a good idea when
[ __ ] starts when they start rounding up
people
like that look like me
with the haircut well and religious
backgrounds such as well right yeah uh
I'm not supposed to go there
I'm just saying right
that's it I can say that right
oh I just had a cough I was just about
to speak Spanish
oh
look at him so what did you guys plans
you're gonna get home you're done yeah
we're gonna what's the first thing you
guys are gonna do
sleep probably just chill yeah sleep in
our our bed with our dog
get Tim Hortons
we missed that [ __ ] what do you get
there just like a coffee you get donuts
yeah we get donuts sometimes the sour
cream glazed donuts [ __ ] crazy okay
yeah it's like your guys is dunking
right yeah but Duncan I [ __ ] I don't
like I don't like the Duncan's trash
yeah I agree Duncan I don't like that
Tim Hortons is it is comparable to like
how how many there are but it's a lot
better
so probably just do that uh
next I think we're I'm doing some shows
in Toronto next like early next year
um because I haven't done there yet and
I lived there
um
but yeah I just keep making [ __ ]
videos I guess that's awesome yeah well
guys uh Curtis Connor is a great dude a
funny man thank you thanks so much for
having very funny man means a lot man
that's really good the YouTube channel
is
the YouTube channel is great it's really
good
um is that what you meant it's Curtis
Connor yeah it's my name yes Curtis it's
Curtis Connor I also it is very good I
also have a podcast called very really
good
um yeah just you know if you want to
watch my videos you can do that but if
not that's fine that's not fine yeah
okay yeah watch my videos are fine watch
my videos or else you're [ __ ] buddy
[ __ ] bro you're a [ __ ] curse for
Life idiot
um yeah and guys remember if you want to
go on tour and it sounds like your tour
is going to keep going on so you guys
can find him of course at shop
.curtisconnor.com what's with the shop
dot you can get the kids no well I don't
know why that happens but you can just
type in curtisconnor.com and it will
redirect you to shop.com
fix that Dan because we don't want the
shop in there right we prefer just
curtisconnor.com it's cleaner drop the
van what can we do about it give me give
me your admin password to your all of
your credentials and I'll take a look
and see what I can do we have people we
have people that can uh whatever you
want I'm an open book
yeah but uh anyway it was awesome to
meet you nice to meet I had a really fun
time it was great meeting you too Jenna
congratulations on being married guys
that's so fun I love I personally love
marriage I think marriage is great
um and I think it's great how long you
guys been together uh seven years almost
it'll be eight almost eight oh wow you
guys waited a long time yeah we waited a
bit were you guys waiting for something
not particularly no I just felt like the
right you know right time you know we
were never in like a you know super big
rush but and and when are we doing
children
probably never really no kids no I don't
think okay yeah I think we that's a
blessed life I mean you have so much
Freedom you guys will have so much
Freedom you've got like you're doing so
you're successful you guys are gonna
have freedom it's gonna be amazing right
we we have a dog and we're okay with
with a dog that's all that's plenty
that's plenty of responsibility for us
but you guys are a little younger than
me how old are you if you don't mind me
30. okay yeah you're a bit younger than
me
yeah but hey who knows maybe I mean
probably
it's really up to Jenna so
you're down no or whatever she wants
kind of thing
I don't know I feel like neither of us
want kids yeah yeah I'm not gonna yeah
there seems to be a little apprehension
over here and it's not that very weird
no it's not apprehensive I don't want to
be the person to be like no it's I don't
yeah
we're on the same page here yeah okay
okay good no kids [ __ ] kids right yeah
do we hate kids why don't we want kids
it's just you know I think they're I
don't think we're ready for that I don't
think we'll be pregnant I don't want to
give birth and I don't want to raise a
child yeah that's everything there you
go you hate everything very solid reason
you know what all those things like
objectively are subjectively all those
things like if you take out like the
love and like the parent stuff and like
those all really [ __ ] suck like those
are all horrible things right so that's
a Vibe I respect that yeah thank you you
guys are gonna have so much fun just
being free right but when you're 50 or
60 you're probably gonna die alone I'm
just saying
we all die alone right
I've heard that but I don't know what
that means why do we die like you don't
die with someone it's you dying but
people can be necked with you yeah but
they're not dying you're dying
you die alone what I gotta maybe you can
die with someone depends how you made it
recycling yeah I guess drunk driving
suicide pods they're driving you heard
about suicide pods no is that where you
I get it pretty self-explained so I
guess you'd go in there but it's a real
thing they invented it in like Denmark
or some crazy place where you can just
where you it's like euthanasia yeah and
you get in the Pod and like you just
[ __ ] die go to bed
yeah a bunch of spikes come out yeah
like the chicken Matilda they put in
some kind of gas or some [ __ ] right I
mean okay that's yeah I was gonna say
like if you could do that with just a
regular just like pod and not just lock
them in and then they die eventually
right like right every pod could be
suicide technically yeah just a matter
of time right
this whole [ __ ] Earth is my Suicide
part
all right guys uh thank you everyone for
watching I had a great time you guys are
awesome I'm super happy for all your
guys success and thank you so much
thanks for having me on that's really
awesome so thank you guys thanks for
watching guys we will uh be here
tomorrow for leftovers and uh Friday
we're going live with
Avi Loeb we're gonna learn about space
is it the final frontier
yes there it is confirm
have the aliens visited the Earth yes
there it is
do aliens Walk Among Us
Among Us
the game yes yeah he said it yes yeah he
said it yeah I did I did all right thank
you guys we'll see you tomorrow peace
and God bless thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]